and for him this really is I was writing
about it last night it feels like
something out of uh of the West Wing
doesn't it the drama the plot twists uh
the infighting I mean you couldn't make
it up in terms of uh art imitating life
if you like all life rather imitating
art this guy was basically down and out
you know he'd blown it if you like he
tried to run as prime minister people
always say you only really get one shot
you only get one chance to either win
the member is over or you don't he was
four he's 42 years old seven years in
Parliament and he must have thought
um at the end of August into September
well my political career is over what do
I do next and now here we are I can
barely believe it's seven weeks later
and he is about to become the Prime
Minister and actually I think that
perhaps what happened to him over the
summer was probably quite character
building for Rishi sonat because to go
through that race and those hustins when
pretty much it was nailed on certainly
from mid-august that he was not going to
win he still had to go through the
motions his team stayed with him and
They carried on right to the bitter and
he did not concede and then you know the
team disbanded I mean it's brutal this
you know the team they worked so hard
over the summer he lost out to Liz trust
they disbanded and then suddenly they
are now in power it's it's quite hard
really to process it I I asked some of
his allies actually yesterday as they
would come in
um into conservative Campaign
Headquarters to cheer him on
um whether he'd been really jubilant
after the vote and they just said not
really he just knows the job at hand and
the responsibility he has that is that
is a difficult job Indeed we are
watching Rishi sunak on his way to that
audience uh with the King we could bring
in our events commentator at Aleister
Bruce because Liz truss has attended her
resignation Richie soon act you can see
there on his way Alistair
thank you
the king is about to appoint Rishi sunak
as
prime minister but first of all he will
ask
whether
there is the possibility of leading a
government and the moment Richardson
answers that question he becomes prime
minister plenty of people there at the
North Center gate seeing as the
procession of cars comes in it'll pass
through the north Arch into the
quadrangle
number seven company Cold Stream guards
forming the King's Guard today on
a long guard there's no Changing of the
Guard ceremony today which makes this
Handover of power easier
and into the quadrangle
now the king will receive Rishi sunak in
the 1844 room which as we looked down at
Buckingham Palace is at the rear of the
building beyond that green roof looking
out onto the garden the car will stop
the footman will open the door and he
will be received
by first of all the kings of query
after Colonel Johnny Thompson and also
the king's principal private secretary
sir Clive Alderson
[Music]
also there the former Queen's private
secretary sir Edward Young
and receiving also
welcomed to in
the palace to the king's door and Rishi
sinak will be escorted through
the palace to the place where the king
will receive him
that's quite a distance in terms of the
corridors and when there the aquarium
will explain precisely how the audience
will take place
and it's traditional that when the king
signals that he is ready a buzzer will
play and
Lieutenant Colonel Johnny Thompson will
open the door and enter and introduce
the right honorable Rishi sunak
and then the king will be left alone and
the moment of asking that question can
you form a government will take place
and the moment Richie sunak says yes he
will become the king's prime minister
and first Lord of the treasury
the tradition has it that
after the initial part of the audience
of the King has taken place
there will be further discussions maybe
not much time spent on this occasion
there's no farewell to be given but a a
very clear amount of work to be done so
quite soon after
the reception and the invitation and the
moment it's taken place
the king will press the buzzer again
and Lieutenant Colonel Johnny Thompson
will come to the door
and in a tradition that went all through
the last Queen's Reign the Aquarius the
first person to say congratulations
prime minister so that will take place
now inside Buckingham Palace as the
Constitutional role of the king is
performed by his majesty on behalf of
the United Kingdom and his
constitutional duties
Aleister thank you very much for all
that analysis and explaining to us what
is happening this morning Rishi sunak
there arriving for his audience with the
king at moments uh earlier of course
today at Liz Truss
at meeting with the King to Tender her
resignation
all we had of course was the short
statement from the Royal Communications
back in Palace the right honorable
Elizabeth trust had an audience with the
King this morning and attended her
resignation as prime minister and first
Lord of the treasury which his magistry
was graciously pleased to accept just
one short sentence of course but so much
of course behind those words as King
Charles meets first to accept the
resignation of Liz trust the shortest
serving prime minister she resigned
after just 45 days in office and to
welcome in Rishi sunak to approve his
appointment as the youngest prime
minister in 200 years the first British
Asian prime minister and also as we've
been discussing here in Downing Street
this morning an incredible amount in his
intree let's bring in our political
editor Beth Ridley at shall we who is
here with us throughout this morning
Rishi Suna currently meeting King
Charles it has been as you said a real
roller coaster for him after the last
leadership contest just seven weeks ago
and what are you expecting to hear from
him later today
well I think what he's going to have to
do later today is talk directly to the
country because now he's not just the
leader of the conservative party he's
about to be the new prime minister and
we did get a big flavor of some of the
things he might talk about because he
did address the 1922 committee he
addressed back bench MPS yesterday and
he also did that very short statement in
um to in in conservative Campaign
Headquarters the first time we'd heard
him speech where he talked about the
need for Unity and he talked about
profound economic challenges that the
country were facing so I would expect
more of that what did he say to MPS last
night well he talked about the economic
crisis and the political crisis
unfolding he told MPS that the public
will hold us accountable for it unless
we fix it now he told them that they
have time before the next election to do
it but he warned that there's only one
shot no Second Chances he described the
place of the conservative party as an
existential moment and I guess that
feeds into the we unite or die so really
warning that unless people get behind
him the party could actually really
split he talked also about Ukraine and
back in the policies of his two
predecessors and on energy he supported
Liz truss's
decisions around protecting households
and that long-term energy plan and then
again as I was saying he talked about
delivering on the 2019 Manifesto uh
let's see if he goes any further I would
advise him not to given how badly that
went wrong for Liz truss it was actually
that fracking vote forced upon the
conservative party by labor MPS that
actually on that Wednesday night became
the unraveling of her amid this chaos
about whether it was a whipped vote with
some MPS just refusing to vote for what
was against the manifesto promises and
clearly really difficult issues in their
constituencies so maybe he will decide
to lean out of any of these unnecessary
confrontations so that was that was kind
of what he spoke about last night I am
sure that he will talk really about
economic plans and Beth we can now see
the lectern uh leaving at number 11. and
a new letter
had a um a Jenga star lectern wasn't it
it was quite um eye-catching should we
say Beth but this one is a bit more
traditional perhaps trying to give a
rather different
um a different look to the Liz truss
lectern the podium is out and it is a
very different one to the one that we
saw at Liz truss bring in everyone got
to choose their own let Zone don't know
their own Podium Beth they do and as you
said you can't see it in shop but this
one is a very solid and stable uh in
sorry that was a bad joke
um in that it's just a straight it's
like a traditional uh lectern you can't
see the um the stand but it's just
straight and and as Sophie was saying
Liz trusted had a sort of Twisted
um sort of curvy uh Twist of a lectin so
you know I don't know if this is a
metaphor of Rishi sonak going back to
the sort of stable politics and stable
economics that he certainly uh talked
about wanting uh to do when he becomes
prime minister this is a huge moment for
him you have to think that as I was
saying seven weeks ago Rishi sunak
thought his political career could be
over uh he resigned as Boris Johnson's
Chancellor uh he then fought Liz trust
and lost he was then booted out of
cabinet and back on the back benches
he's kept his Council we have barely
seen nor heard from him for the past few
weeks and I guess the thing about this
coronation rather than a contest is that
we really don't know what Rishi sanak as
prime minister will do given that
everything he said in the run-up to
becoming prime minister was in August
and the world has changed so much in
such a short space of time to the
decisions that Liz truss has made so
let's see what he says I imagine it will
be a big focus on economy let's see if
he talks about tough decisions on tax
and spend let's see if he as he did in
the leadership contest levels with the
British public the challenges ahead it
might be better for him to do that given
that we know it's going to be a very
very bumpy period yeah certainly will uh
Beth we can see a bit more at the
lecture in shot the solid and stable
Podium was back it was just to start
describing it there's a single glass of
water on top of it because it certainly
is going to be an important speech for
Rishi Scenic he's spoken to the party so
far but really heard very little out
from him as Beth was saying during this
short leadership campaign he will be
wanting to address the public later
it'll be interesting to see if he
decides to flesh out a bit more of his
vision for the country when he does take
to the steps to hear the sound tests
going on there as well as we're talking
though King Charles of course currently
inviting Rishi soon act to form a new
government they are in Buckingham Palace
let's bring in our events commentator
now shall we Aleister Bruce Alastair
the king is receiving the right
honorable Richie sunac in the 1844 room
which looks at Over The Gardens of
Buckingham Palace to the left of our
picture down there and it is a tradition
that the king theoretically doesn't know
what we all know and therefore receives
politicians and wants to know the answer
as to whether the new politician he's
about to make prime minister actually
can command a majority in the House of
Commons which is the key element as head
of state the Monarch needs to know the
meeting as I say in the 1844 room which
was decorated for a visit in that year
by Tsar Alexander the first of Russia
and I'm sure that one of the matters
upon which the king will wish to talk to
his new prime minister is the issue that
is going on in the world and
particularly in Europe with Russia but
the responsibility of government is
finally given to Rishi sunak as prime
minister and first Lord of the treasury
when he says yes to the invitation from
the King can you form a government and
we know that he will say yes because we
are aware from everything Beth has been
telling us that Rishi sunak can command
a majority in the House of Commons for
the king of course it starts a
relationship which will pass forward
with weekly audiences here of the king
at Buckingham Palace they're always
audiences of a monarch because it is the
monarch who is receiving the Prime
Minister as head of government and then
listens and after all the prime minister
act in the king's name the cabinet
operates the executive authority of the
king we know that Kings carry out no
executive functions in reality they do
it on advice
and the principal advisor of course will
be the new prime minister the title of
first Lord of the treasury which is on
the letterbox just behind the new Podium
is a reminder that that was always where
real Authority lay right back for kings
in the times of not only soon after the
conquest but right through our history
that whoever held the treasury was
principally important and that is why
the prime ministership has always walked
in recent times with that the king's
standard flies and I'm sure by now
although we'll wait for it to be
confirmed by Buckingham Palace we have a
new prime minister
we do have a new uh prime minister uh
very shortly as to Bruce just saying
King Charles inviting Rishi sunak to
form a new government after that meeting
with Liz truss where he accepted her
resignation earlier
this morning
well let's bring in Beth Rigby shall we
I would always love to be you know fly
on the wall on some of these meetings
the kind of intimate meetings between
King Charles and the prime ministers and
it's quite remarkable isn't it thinking
about this trust meeting of course the
Queen just before she died and now she
will be she has met with at King Charles
earlier today but things will be moving
very quickly uh Rishi sunak will be
traveling back here to Downing Street
he'll be giving a speech at the lectern
that's just been brought out and really
a huge interest for the next prime
minister yes and I'm picking up a little
bit about you know we're talking about
the change of tone the change of style
you know we've got a different lecture
but I've also been told that Mal stride
one of his key lieutenants has emailed
MPS to tell them there's not going to be
a throng of advisors coming out and MPS
in the street as Boris Johnson and Liz
Tross has done before I'm told by
someone in his team it's just going to
be Richardson like no one else in the
street now I don't know if his family
will be there he's got two young
daughters I don't know if they might um
might stand by his side or he will come
out alone I don't know about his family
but in terms of the politics of it it's
not a big kind of celebratory show of
support it's going to be just Rishi Suna
can I also wonder and I don't know this
but the fact that it smell stride who
was one of his organizers emailing MPS
does that mean and this is a guess does
that mean that male stripe might become
his chief work because he's very trusted
by Richardson I don't know
um I can't get any confirmation from
that they're being very tight-lipped
about the reshuffle but but but that he
has emailed MPS saying let's not show up
this isn't a big celebration I think
speaks to the tone the change of tone
that Rishi sanak is going to want to try
and introduce when he takes up the reins
at number 10. and it'll be interesting
so I won't to see if his family is there
we saw of course Liz trust her husband
and her two daughters there and when
Boris Johnson gave his resignation
speech Carrie and their children too but
of course Richard sunac has been unhappy
hasn't he with some of the focus on his
family uh in you know recent months
about the tax status of his wife um was
speculating of course but it'll be
interesting to see if he does decide to
continue that tradition and part of his
family on the stream well actually when
Liz truss was came from is her children
weren't there her husband was there but
her children weren't there and when
Boris Johnson left number 10 yes Carrie
came out with the baby with Romy the
baby but the baby's tiny so you know she
was carrying her in a sling but when
they left number 10 the children weren't
there and actually Boris Johnson and
Carrie Johnson definitely tried to keep
their two young children out of the
Limelight and Liz trust as I said did
there was Francis and Liberty her two
teenage doors it's the first time I'd
ever seen them I didn't even know
actually if they'd moved in uh to number
10 and I didn't ask I didn't think it
was my business they're our children
um but in terms of Rishi sunax family
you're right there was a massive
controversy around his wife the fact
that she was a non-dom uh and had
therefore followed tax laws was meant
she'd avoided a lot of tax now they was
in the rules
um I asked for she said like exactly
about this at the July launch when he
launched his um leadership that was this
a problem and he did make the point that
the tax arrangements had changed his
wife is now
no removed her non-dom status
um and and that she had answered that
question for herself and as far as he
was concerned that that drew a line
under the matter but I think there's a
couple of things to say on that number
one when that all blew up I think it was
last April or so uh that his wife was
was a non-dom and also that he had had
which I think he has now doesn't have
but had had a green card which basically
means you can move to America whenever
you want these did raise questions about
whether he could therefore stand as
prime minister I remember at the time we
would go oh that's it Rishi sunax crew
is over he's never going to get past
this with the British public
um and yet now he is prime minister now
he would say he and his family have
answered those questions his wife has
changed
tax Arrangements I've asked him about
his privilege he went to I think it was
Winchester was it Winchester
a very a very very very very prestigious
public school I asked him about this in
an interview we did actually earlier
this year about who was Rishi sunak and
would this privilege be a barrier to
success his wife is the daughter of one
of the richest men in India you know his
father-in-law is a billionaire they are
multi-millionaires his argument was you
know his parents were pharmacists I
think or one of his they were in
pharmacist and GPU a GP that was a
pharmacist and a GP his argument was
they they'd saved up and worked hard to
get him that education and and that he
was someone that was in touch with the
British people now the question is the
obvious attack lines for labor is to try
and paint Rishi sunak as a privileged
person out of touch with ordinary
working people and they will be the
attack lines and which is and his family
might have to absorb some of that but as
I said it it's curious that these things
that were these sort of massive
political barriers to him in the end it
seems impossible in that moment but
actually he managed to get past that and
as I said his wife did change her tax
Arrangements there were some reports
over the weekend
um that when Liz trosser resigned and
then this all happened so quickly I mean
it was Thursday she resigned and Monday
we have a new prime minister that he
went to talk to his wife about whether
or not she was prepared for him to take
this office and the inevitable scrutiny
that comes with it so it might be that
because of all of this that his family
want to stay behind the scenes but we'll
find out soon enough yeah and as you say
it's a huge thing for any family of
course entering Downing Street and only
seeing Liz trussler's daughters really
for the first time today as she resigns
as prime minister well we're still
looking at those pictures at Buckingham
Palace where King Charles is inviting
Rishi soon Act form a new government and
some of the Constitutional measures that
always have to be gone through of course
with the appointment of any new prime
minister and new government he's there
in Buckingham Palace we expect him to
leave from there and come to Downing
Street where he's going to be giving a
speech from the new Lech town the
different lectern and the one that Liz
class had and really it's his time to
talk to the British people directly like
he's been quite tight-lipped throughout
the very truncated very short leadership
contest but we do expect to hear a bit
more from him later on today and Beth of
course here to pick up any intelligence
that we're getting Mel stride as you
were saying a key Ally of Rishi student
already emailing at MP so perhaps our
first clue as to who could be by his
side as he does form a new government
well I expected a male stride is the
very respected chair of the treasury
select committee and someone that was
making it um pretty hard I should say
for Liz truss over those uh policies
asking her for reversals trying to
bounce so as many other MPS did and
forcing those reversals now people that
battle is trust and people that don't
much like Rishi sunak felt that his
allies tried to destabilize his trust
from the outset be that Michael Gove be
that Grant chaps who she then actually
brought into cabinet be that someone
like Mel stride so yes those people I
would imagine all have key roles in his
government but equally
um don't underestimate that there is
still bitter blood over the way in which
Liz trust some of her allies would say
was never given an opportunity now she
didn't help herself clearly but there
was a lot of agitating because of the
policies to be fair to to the likes of
male stride I mean you know the markets
um your best poll ever aren't they they
tell you exactly immediately what they
think and she got her answer I remember
on that day saying it might be that the
biggest story here is actually how the
markets react yes and that is how it
played out because you know those
unfunded tax cards that went beyond what
she'd said it just spooked the markets
and I did think in the run-up to her
becoming prime minister I thought that
maybe she might keep the principles of
the tax cuts but stage them in a way
that brought the markets all the party
around she chose not to follow that
strategy she paid a heavy price Rishi
sonat will have looked and learned and
let's see what type of inclusivity he
tries to bring to this government
whether or not he can rebuild the party
is an entirely uh different subject that
we could probably spend a few hours uh
debating but for now let's see about the
inclusivity let's see what he says to
the country and let's see about the
change in style as well yeah we've
already had some Clues as to the
changing style haven't been the letter
and the fact that we now know that there
won't be the crowds of supportive MPS
and and also staff members as well on
the street just Rishi Cena giving a very
serious speech we expect from a very
serious looking lectern as well and Beth
you were just talking about the
inclusivity Mel stride someone who of
course has done an awful lot of legwork
at the richest sunak over the last
couple of months but someone who's made
some enemies in the process particularly
among those supporters of Liz trussen
potentially Boris Johnson as well are
there any names that you were looking
out for when he does decide to form a
government I mean Michael Gove is
someone that a few people mentioned
isn't it that would be extraordinary
comeback wouldn't it
I don't think Michael's game will be an
extraordinary combat because Michael
gave clearly set himself apart from his
trust there were Rumors in the
Parliamentary party that he had back
Cami Baden Ock precisely to try and
split the right between Bravo and trust
and badanoch in order to try and uh
block Liz truss will make it very
difficult for her and then he became
didn't he
um the leader of the Rebel Alliance as
he was described at conference going on
to the airwaves uh the morning of Party
Conference and basically publicly
attacking some of Liz truss's policies
particularly the 45 Pence tax rate which
you know with 24 hours she had she had
to uh reverse so I think that behind the
scenes perhaps Michael Gove has been an
ally a friend and a confidante of
Richardson potentially so I wouldn't be
surprised at all to see uh Michael Gove
back in cabinet going back to what you
were saying about Mel stride and the
fact that he might put some people's
backs up though do you think that the
bringing you know people like Michael
Gove who obviously you know played such
a big role as you were saying you know
in trying to well some would say trying
to knifeless trumps and trying to get it
to reverse on things and how do you
think that would be for party Unity
though
well as I was saying earlier I think
part of the issue around this is that
what Michael gave needs to do is bring
the best experienced cabinet ministers
to the table in order to try and fix
some of the problems not just in the
economy but in other Departments of the
government I mean this government has
been this party has been wrestling
whether to not to ask Boris Johnson and
then wrestling with who uh to put back
in and then wrestling about whether or
not to
oust or not Liz trust from June or May
onwards really I mean it's been months
that this chaos and this infighting and
a party looking inward rather than
focusing on governing the country and
changing all the people uh running
departments it's been going on and on
for months and so what Rishi Suna has to
do is he has to study the ship he has to
get a cabinet of all the different parts
of the party in order to try and I don't
know if he succeed but try and unify and
he will want also to get experienced
cabinet ministers who know what they're
doing that can at the ground running
back into departments and that's what
I'm expecting to see from this reshuffle
I have to say
his team have been extremely
tight-lipped so everything I'm picking
up from the reshuffle is basically you
know from parliamentary sources and
other and other government sources but
the actual core team are keeping their
cars close to the chest but he obviously
would have thought about it when you run
to be leader you know you have your key
team around them and they do expect to
be rewarded and it will bring in a new
change of thought I'm really interested
to see though does he keep any of the
key Liz Truss It does he keep his
example Trey's coffee her Deputy Prime
Minister who I think everyone would
agree in government in the Parliamentary
party did a really good job as Chief
Secretary of State for Department of
work and pensions during the covid
crisis you know there wasn't a big blow
up in the benefits system it was
ferociously difficult to manage that
Michigan would have worked with her
really closely because he was the
chancellor I know that they came to
blows over issues around operating
benefits over issues about trying to
keep that uplifting Universal Credit the
20 pounds a week that was so necessary
for so many people during the pandemic
you know they they tussled over they
tussled over funding and spending but I
wonder does he keep to raise coffee in
you know is there is there some sort of
offer
signal also to trust sites that's the
question as well interesting stuff we
will of course find out later on at this
afternoon I think we should be able to
have a look now at some pitchings that
we have got of Russia sunac meeting with
King Charles there they are at
Buckingham Palace all smiles two men as
they meet and of course King Charles
that formally invites Richardson act to
form a new government well let's bring
in our events commentator Alistair Bruce
shall we the picture there of them
shaking hands
it is the start of the audience that the
king will have given and will have now
proceeded probably towards its close
it's quite moving to the first time that
the king receives someone and invites
them to form a government and we
remember the photograph quite recently
of his mother the queen inviting Richard
sunax predecessor not so long ago up at
Balmoral but for the king a chance to
talk and he always allows the chance of
pictures to be taken before the doors
are closed and it would have been behind
closed doors that the King Alone with
Rishi sunak would have invited him to
become the head of government and to
give him therefore as Sovereign the
leadership of the executive of the
United Kingdom photographs now just
released
and Alistair I'm always so fascinated to
know what goes on with these audiences
but they're always so
tightly controlled aren't we just get
the briefest of statements from the
palace and just give me the facts on
what took place with Liz Strauss earlier
today but Prime Ministers really value
them don't they and I'm sure that will
be no different
the palace always balances the fact that
there is public interest in seeing the
meeting of the head of state and the
head of government but also that this is
a very private moment so you have to
balance those by getting the photograph
at the beginning and these photographs
were clearly taken as the king received
Rishi sunak right after he had been
introduced to him by the Kings aquarium
Lieutenant Colonel Johnny Thompson but
then you know once those doors are
closed and until any prime minister
breaks the code we're just not going to
know what goes on we know
constitutionally that the King has the
right to know what is going on he has
the privilege of being able to give
warning or to take advice or or even to
just in every way interrogate the Prime
Minister but also the Prime Minister has
a chance to talk in complete confidence
with a sort of a bunk killer figure of
his Sovereign and that relationship is
perhaps the only place a prime minister
can find that kind of confidentiality so
so these photographs do Mark the
beginning of a relationship between head
of government with the head of state the
King which will take its Journey forward
and it's going to be such a challenging
leadership and Premiership by Rishi
sunak as prime minister and I'm sure all
the way through the king will be deeply
conscious of his constitutional position
as head of state and wanting that the
progress be done in the most effective
way for the benefit of all people who
live in the United Kingdom
and Alistair you know just to be really
Frank with you not I find it quite
arresting in some ways seeing King
Charles uh inviting these new prime
minister in uh for an audience with him
of course his mother met with Liz trust
who one of her very first meetings to
appoint her as prime minister and now it
is her son who was taking on that role
it must be quite poignant for the new
king not just of course because of the
huge constitutional moment but also for
the past moment too
for the king remembering too that you
know moments like when his grandfather
King George VI in that difficult time in
the second world war had to choose who
to call as prime minister between Lord
Halifax and Winston Churchill
and it is carrying on that battle
through time that goes really back to
the start of Cabinet Government and of
course King George the first when he
arrived in 1714 didn't speak English and
it became more and more necessary for
the cabinet to act more and more for the
king in fact the cabinet room at number
10 dining Street has one chair around
the table with arms which is the King's
chair and it is that chair that is only
given up by Prime Ministers to the king
but when the king is not present the
Prime Minister sits in it and in a way
that again reminds everyone of how it is
the King's executive power as Sovereign
that is being carried out by all those
who the Prime Minister nominates to and
the King accepts which we will probably
see happen over the next few hours to be
the administration or cabinet and the
executive leadership of the United
Kingdom
thank you Alistair we of course are
still looking at those pictures of Bucky
and Palace we are expecting the car to
leave carrying Rishi sunak when he has
become the new prime minister or as he's
become the new
prime minister leaving their
making his way
here to Downing Street where he will
address the nation and of course those
pictures there are just released of King
Charles meeting with Rishi sunak
well let's bring in our battery out
shall we wish you soon act has become
the new prime minister we've seen those
pictures of him with Prince Charles with
King Charles I should say and the body
language between them all smiles all
handshakes but now I guess it's down to
business for the new prime minister John
I think we should pause for a moment and
just take in what a historic moment this
is because Rishi sanak is the fast
British Asian prime minister he's the
first Hindu prime minister I think
Disraeli was Jewish but apart from that
I think all prime ministers have been
Christian by religious denomination so
he's the first Hindu promise this is a
huge moment for the country he's also
the second ever the second youngest ever
prime minister since William the Pitt
the younger back in the uh 18th century
so this really is a big moment for the
country that we have our fast
British Asian prime minister
and I think that that will mean a lot a
lot symbolically to a lot of people
around the country so I think it's worth
saying that and marking that
um in terms of his age though and
experience I think it's also fair to say
that he has one hell of an entree for a
guy that is 42 that has only been in
politics as a backbencher and then into
the treasury for seven years
um he was of course a successful
financier before that he worked at a big
hedge fund he did an MBA a business
degree
um
in California where he met his wife so
he had a very successful career and
became very wealthy in his own right
before he entered politics but when you
when he talks about kind of what drives
him he genuinely talks a lot about a
sense of his uh desire to serve the
public and public service he talks about
that a lot what will his style be as I
was saying earlier you know when I spoke
to some of his team shortly after he was
anointed as party leader and therefore
prime minister and I said is he you know
is he delighted did he was he Overjoyed
how did he react I mean they they really
did say that he was
um
you know not ecstatic that he talked
about the big responsibility he had now
and I think that that will be the style
of richardsonac it will be straight to
business it will be low-key
um it will be none of the flourish of
Boris Johnson and I I don't think it
will be
the ideological Zeal either of Liz truss
I think he will try and Forge a
different path where he tries to get the
economy back on track I mean he has such
a difficult task ahead of him it would
be difficult for any politician right
now given the challenges the country
faces his task is obviously being
exacerbated and made more difficult by
the decisions of his predecessor and he
not only now has a bigger economic
problem on his hands because of the
decisions made by Liz truss and
quasiquarter but he also has a big
political problem in terms of a party
that is Riven with divisions internally
and also a country that does not much
like the look of the conservative party
at the moment so he's got kind of Triad
from policy to politics to the public
he's got a Triad of difficulties and
challenges that he has to try and
grapple it is a huge job he faces
yeah it really it is as well and it's
worth pausing isn't it Beth because you
know we've been talking about the fact
that he is as you said you know the
youngest prime minister for 200 years
he's had a remarkable rise in Parliament
after only being elected as an MP in
2015 only seven years in Parliament but
at the same time it's been a pretty
bruising few years for him as the
chancellor of course in times of Kobe
then he had that remarkable Fallout with
Boris Johnson as well and then the
brutal leadership election at two which
he lost at the first time around earlier
this year so I guess even though he is a
relevant a relative newcomer in terms of
parliament how long has been here and
the fact he's quite young in years
compared to other previous Prime
Ministers it's been quite the ride isn't
it
I think being Chancellor during a
pandemic where he had to embark on the
biggest spending program that any
government had seen since World War II
and then he had so many emergency
statements I mean it was it was just uh
incredible to behold that was a big big
task he had
um but then he did get into hot water
really politically because he then had
to do the hard work which was trying to
raise taxes in order to stop beginning
to to pay down some of the debt or fund
Public Services I mean I think the thing
that you can understand about where she
saw that approach to the economy is it
is economic Orthodoxy in the sense that
this is a chancellor and now prime
minister that would want uh debt falling
as a percentage of GDP he would want to
put in fiscal rules he doesn't want to
spend beyond means
uh we can go back to Buckingham Palace
now because there is movement at the
palace Alistair what can you see
the Prime Minister taking leave there of
the king's private secretary and former
Queen's private secretary
will maintain
regular conversations with the prime
minister in fact they probably
had a chance to talk after the king
appointed
his new prime minister
there's a lot to do and the relationship
with the palace underscores the fact
that
whilst head of government
the new prime minister will always act
on behalf of the United Kingdom and The
King
it takes leave of Lieutenant Colonel
Johnny Thompson the query who is always
on the king's path the last to say
goodbye
and this brief moment of the
Constitution playing its part and of the
monarch inviting
a new prime minister to take the Helm of
the United Kingdom's government
is done and for this prime minister who
may have discussed with the King his
plans for the government
and who will be in and who won't be and
over the next days we will see new
ministers and old ministers come to
Buckingham Palace in order to both
confirm
that they hand over their seals of
office and also to receive new ones from
the King always underscoring that the
Constitutional process is observed
but for the palace and relationship
begun and for almost leaving the
relative peace and calm of his time with
the King and returning out to where
quite a crowd has gathered at the North
Center gate we saw the king's lifeguard
of the Blues and Royals who had just
dismounted and with the other reaction
the Prime Minister will return now past
the Queen Victoria Memorial a route that
we know from all the great moments of
recent times in the nation's story and
he will go the short distance up the
Mull and turn right towards number 10
dining Street and with the remit from
the king of the invitation to former
government he now must and he must then
prove to the king that he can command a
majority for
his government on the floor of the House
of Commons
Aleister thank you very much indeed the
Constitutional moment the 57th prime
minister the first British Asian prime
minister Rishi sunak making his way from
Buckingham Palace now to dami Street
where he will take up residence as the
new prime minister
and it's already of course been such a
busy morning Liz truss is speaking to
King Charles earlier today already feels
like ancient history now of course it
was a turn of Rishi sunak had those
images released by The Palace of him
shaking hands with King Charles all
smiles as he was officially invited to
form the government and now making his
way you can see there through London
with the motorcade
and his car behind
traveling to number 10 where really that
he faces an enormous entry for any prime
minister 40 billion pounds a black hole
we believe in the public finances
inflation already so high and of course
a fractures and divided conservative
party as well as
he makes his way or do you wonder what
he's thinking that you know in the back
of that car perhaps making the finishing
touches to his speech that he'll be
giving in number 10 Downing Street
shortly
speaking to the country after yesterday
he spoke to
his party and he's just turning down now
it looks like onto White Hall just
moments away from Downing streets
and Beth we can um
the gates of Downing Street now opening
you can see the policeman there
waving in the car so we really are just
moments away now from seeing the new
prime minister arriving and just On Cue
Larry the camp her exiting the door of
number 10 incredible timing there from
from Larry
and here we are
the car now turning
into Downing Street
um
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
people
heckling the new prime minister
Sometimes some things never change
and that car now putting up into into
Downing Street the gates are now closed
and we should get the Glimpse
first glimpse of Rishi sunak as prime
minister as he leaves the car
chance of course under Boris Johnson he
resigned now second time running
he won the conservative leadership
contest and is now the new prime
minister
good morning
I've just been to Buckingham Palace
and accepted his majesty the king's
invitation to form a government in his
name
it is only right
to explain why I'm standing here
as your new prime minister
right now
our country is facing a profound
economic crisis
the aftermath of covid still lingers
Putin's war in Ukraine has destabilized
energy markets and Supply chains the
world over
I want to pay tribute to my predecessor
Liz Truss
she was not wrong to want to improve
growth in this country
it is a noble aim
and I admired her restlessness to create
change
but some mistakes were made
not born of ill will or bad intentions
quite the opposite in fact
that mistakes nonetheless
and I have been elected as leader of my
party
and your prime minister
in part
to fix them
and that work begins immediately
I will place economic stability and
confidence
at the heart of this government's agenda
this will mean difficult decisions to
come
but you saw me
during covid doing everything I could to
protect people and businesses
with schemes like furlough
there are always limits
more so now than ever
that I promise you this
I will bring that same compassion
to the challenges we face today
the government I lead
will not leave the Next Generation
your children and grandchildren
with a debt to settle that we were too
weak to pay ourselves
I will unite our country
not with words
but with action
I will work day in and day out to
deliver for you
this government
will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
Trust
is earned and I will earn yours
I will always be grateful to Boris
Johnson for his incredible achievements
as prime minister
and I treasure his warmth and generosity
of spirit
and I know he would agree
that the Mandate my party earned in 2019
is not the sole property of any one
individual
it is a mandate
that belongs to and unites all of us
and the Heart of that mandate is our
Manifesto
I will deliver on its promise
a stronger NHS
better schools
safer streets control of our borders
protecting our environment supporting
our Armed Forces leveling up
and building an economy that Embraces
the opportunities of brexit where
businesses invest innovate and create
jobs
I understand
how difficult this moment is
after the billions of pounds it cost us
to combat covid
after all the dislocation that caused in
the midst of a terrible war that must be
seen successfully to its conclusions
I fully appreciate how hard things are
and I understand too
that I have work to do to restore trust
after all that has happened
all I can say
is that I am not daunted
I know the high office I have accepted
and I hope to live up to its demands
but when the opportunity to serve comes
along
you cannot question the moment only your
willingness
so I stand here before you
ready to lead our country into the
future
to put your needs above politics
to reach out and build a government that
represents the very best traditions of
my party
together we can achieve incredible
things
we will create a future
worthy of the sacrifices so many have
made
and Phil tomorrow
and every day thereafter
with hope
thank you
[Music]
do you like the party
how do you unite the party prime
minister
do you think the the new prime minister
posing for a few photos after making his
speech on the steps of Downing Street it
was a speech directed at the public I
will work day in day out for you but he
also had a few words to say about his
previous as a bitless trust had a noble
aim to improve growth but some mistakes
were made I've been elected to fix them
as he enters number 10 as prime minister
back that's his team inside and you can
hear them as he goes in they all line up
as you go in and I'm sure we'll get
pictures later of him uh being ushered
in uh with the new team and a new start
for number 10 again uh the second prime
minister to have been appointed by the
conservative party without an election
as many opposition politicians are
pointing out in a space of just seven
weeks but look what was that speech
about I think the fast thing to say is
he said what Liz trust did not the first
thing he said was mistakes were made it
wasn't from ill will I respect her
restlessness to get things done but for
the states were made and I was partly
elected to fix them or appointed to fix
them so that was the first thing he said
he acknowledged to the public the
mistakes and he also acknowledged that
he as the new Prime Minister had work to
do to restore Trust of the British
people so I think that was the first key
Point acknowledging what Liz truss
wouldn't lay in it straight with the
British people as well he then the
second sort of section of that speech
was what is my agenda and he was
absolutely crystal clear about that it
was about putting in his words economic
stability and confidence at the heart of
this government's agenda so there he was
saying I understand the economic turmoil
we have created or helped create by
these bad decisions these mistakes I
will try and put it right but then there
was some leveling with the public as
well he said that will mean that
difficult decisions have to come and
that of course is a nod to that
all-important fiscal statement the tax
and spend policies he then and I think
this was
an attempt to distance from Boris
Johnson and Lee's trust and the chaos
that both of them in different ways
brought upon down the street and
Parliament he spoke about uniting with
words not with actions uh not words he
also spoke and this was critical I
thought in terms of him trying to put
clearly water between himself and
predecessors about integrity
professionalism and I can't remember the
third one actually but integrity and
professionalism and he said that he's
going to get on with the job and that is
integrity accountability and
professionalism are the three watch
words of his government
um then there was stuff about
unification because he talked about Liz
truss in quite warm terms before he
criticized her saying I admired her
restlessness I appreciated what she was
trying to do he then went on to talk
about Boris Johnson he said he was
grateful to him for his incredible
people achievements and his warmth and
generosity of spirit was something
people treasured just to mark that we're
now at 12 o'clock we are here in Downing
Street uh I'm with Beth Rigby and we are
digesting at the Rishi sunak statement
Beth
yeah as I was saying so I he was he was
talking about uh Boris Johnson uh he you
know in Praise Him Boris Johnson is an
attempt to put an olive branch out
really I think to those who were
johnsonites that are very unhappy about
a Richie sanak government
and then in terms of the party and
trying to unite the party he talked
about the manifesto saying that that was
the Mandate on which he would now uh run
the government there was no new agenda
for Rishi sanak beyond that reiteration
of committing to trying to get back to a
position of economic stability it was
rather about delivering on the manifesto
and then the final element of what I
think was a very well constructed speech
actually uh was Rishi the man if you
like Rishi sunak the man and this is
where as I was saying earlier this idea
of Public Service came to the fore he
said again I want to restore trust after
all that's happened he said I'm not
daunted I appreciate how hard things are
a message to the public like he
understands uh the difficulties people
are having he said when the opportunity
to serve comes I you cannot question the
moment he said I stand ready and I
thought this was a really key line to
put your needs above politics and what
is that that's a nod to the fact he
understands as does the Parliamentary
party that the public are sick and tired
of these endless Tory Wars that have
brought down two prime ministers in
three months and brought all this
political and economic turbulence and
there he says I want to put your needs
as the public above politics and reach
out to represent the best traditions of
my party uh he said that he wants to
fill tomorrow with hope and with that he
went in so I think one what are the
elements acknowledging the mistakes
trying to reach out to Rivals praising
Boris Johnson economic stability at the
heart of government won't be go beyond
the terms that they had with the British
public that elected them in 2019 and
then a message that I am not Boris
Johnson I am not Liz truss I am a
different leader and I will put
accountability and integrity and
professionalism at the heart of my
government so that is the Rishi sonak
pitch to voters and the party let's see
how it goes like you say a direct pitch
there to voters as well what perhaps
we've been lacking from him in the last
week or so at talking about putting
their needs at first
um just looking at some of the details
for speech back I kind of wonder if what
we're going to be talking about in the
weeks to come is a section on economic
stability that you were talking about
the difficult decisions to come here he
was talking wasn't he about he wouldn't
be a prime minister to put debt onto to
your children and grandchildren that we
were too weak to pay off I mean is that
the Crux of it really yeah
it's a chance to like you know such a
job before him and George Osborne before
him
um and Philip Hammond before him or
between him between him and Osborne
um or the this is a sort of tradition of
conservative chances which is fiscal
rules and actually
um for decades or well many years and
but that's how the treasury has been run
there's a set of fiscal rules and you
set your fiscal framework and you
instruct the markets about you know how
you intend to bait down debt on what
period and how you're going to borrow
money and that's the framework within
which you do your business in which you
make your tax and spend policies and all
issues and that's really going back to
is kind of Treasury Orthodoxy if you
like which is I don't want to Laden our
grandchildren with debt by borrowing to
fund tax taxes Liz truss did in order to
boost growth that was her argument that
you would boost growth the tax revenue
would therefore go up because the
economy is growing you get a
trickle-down effect Rishi sunak is is
signaling that he's going to go back to
a more traditional way of running the
economy which is clearly what the
markets want because uh when Boris
Johnson revealed that he was withdrawing
from the race at the weekend you know
all the market response was positive
active that markets like Michigan they
like Jeremy Hunt in the treasury in and
Rishi sanak in as prime minister so I I
think that all that's the signal so far
I should caution because let's see what
they do but I think that the key thing
of this is that he is wants to put
economic credibility at the heart of the
government but he was also cleared that
involves difficult decisions and this is
where if you like the rubber hits the
road because then what he has to do is
he has to make tax and spend decisions
as I was saying earlier there could be a
multi-billion TENS of billions of pounds
of a fiscal black hole the gap between
your tax commitments and your spending
commitments and how do you feel that and
how do you signal to the market that you
can begin to pay down this mountain of
debt that was built up during covid and
is now building up again even more
because of the need to fund and support
energy bills so these are really really
intractable
decisions and difficult decisions for
any Chancellor and prime minister and he
has to take that on and when he does
take that on that could be very
difficult with the Parliamentary party
and the public yeah he said he wanted to
show compassion well that is going to be
hard as you say at the time when he's
also pitting fiscal responsibility at
the heart of government
um let's just bring in a quick tweet
shall we because Boris Johnson has just
tweeted to say congratulations to Richie
sunac on this historic day this is the
moment for every conservative to give a
new prime minister their full and
wholehearted support and this is of
course a key because Boris Johnson and
what happens most importantly to his
supporters in Parliament it could be
absolutely critical to whether or not
Richie sunac does manage to achieve the
unity that he hopes to and Bethany were
talking earlier weren't you about the
kind of praise to Boris Johnson in the
speech but I did think you were right to
point out that perhaps the line about
bringing back integrity was a bit of a
dig at the former prime minister as well
how difficult do you think it will be
for him to bring those johnsonites if
you like back into the fault well that's
the big question I mean that is the
question in terms of the political
management of the party
um that I think will be something that
will be very live and and we will be
watching very carefully a couple of
things I would say about that was that
on the face of it yesterday after Boris
Johnson withdrew from the race on Sunday
night there were very public backers of
Boris Johnson such as pretty Patel James
cleverley Nadine zahawi that then folded
into the Rishi sanat camp and said that
they would serve him but the Boris
Johnson I'm not standing
um statement was like the most Boris
Johnson type of statement you could ever
imagine in that he said I could if I
wanted to but actually the party don't
want me to and Rishi and and Penny won't
do deals with me so I've got no option
but to to to not go for it so it wasn't
done in a it was done in a way that was
quite agitating I would say
um and and some of his supporters will
have read that and you know Nadine Dory
is one of his key backers already saying
you know there should be a general
election rather than uh just saying
rather that Boris Johnson's the only one
really with the Mandate because he won
the general election and I wonder at the
moment
um many Boris Johnson backers that I
wanted to speak to today are asked to
come up yesterday or ask the common
camera they just wanted to keep out of
it because I think there is a sort of
tradition if you like or convention
that if your person wins and you're on
the losing side you bow out for a bit
you give them a bit of space you allow
them to have a go you have what is
described as a honeymoon period I mean
that is typically what happens when when
someone becomes the new prime minister
now in the case of Liz tras the
honeymoon period didn't happen because
the policies that she introduced so
rapidly uh created this massive backlash
in the markets and then you know and
then what flowed flowed but I think that
I think for Russia sunak I think that
there is a party that is wearied and
bloodied
think maybe that they want a period of
calm I think he might be given some
space but I say all of that Sophie with
the caution that next Monday if this
fiscal statement goes ahead as is
planned they will want to do it on
October 31st the reason is is the
monetary policy Committee of the bank of
England will set interest rates on
November the 2nd right and what they do
with interest rates which has a massive
impact on all of us that could
um
be partly affected by the decisions the
government make ahead of it right so I
don't see that statement moving from
October the 31st so I see it happening
before November the 2nd and at that
point if Richardson act really does set
out the tax and spend envelopes and he
makes decisions on how to operate
benefits is in line with inflation or is
it in line with earnings obviously if
it's in line with earnings people on
benefits are taking a pay cut and I
should say that 42 of recipients of
Universal Credit or Working Families
this sort of notion that it's people
that don't work or people that have
disabilities or they're on for reasons
they can't work that's not entirely true
so these are people that are often
working and they're just in low-paid
jobs and they're struggling to make ends
meet so there's a big push in the party
to operate with inflation there was a
big push as well to stick to the triple
lock as you remember that's when you
lift
pensions by wages earn or inflation
depending on which is highest well
inflation you know list just committed
to doing that last week in the Commons
facing a backlash it costs 5.6 billion
pounds just like that okay these are
massive decisions there's a massive
impact on the public finances and and he
has to lay all of that out and I think
whether it's Rishi sunup whether it's
list trust you know whether it was Boris
Johnson whether it's Jeremy whether it's
Penny Morden these are extremely
extremely difficult decisions and he did
say that it's going to be difficult but
the good will of the British people with
this government at the moment is pretty
much dried up there is not much of a
well of sympathy or tolerance I would
say and then there's going to be these
series of very difficult decisions to
take so it could be very very bumpy for
him in very very quickly bumpy for him
and also for the rest of the country as
well Beth thank you very much indeed for
your analysis this morning Beth will be
there after school editor was into very
different speeches this morning from Liz
truss who was standing by her pro-growth
low tax economic plan and then of course
we've just heard from the new prime
minister of Rishi sunic mistakes were
made it's his job to fix them well we're
joined now by the conservative MP Philip
Dunn thank you very much for being on
the program this morning at Mr Dunn well
it was pretty a blunt wasn't it from
Richie sunac as some mistakes were made
I've been elected to fix them and that
begins immediately is he right
well I think that was a
characteristically impressive
performance from the new prime minister
and he was focusing on the need for his
government to show Integrity
accountability and professionalism and I
think that will characterize his
approach to the very difficult
challenges that we've got ahead as Beth
was just outlining there
he was right to say that they are
difficult challenges ahead
difficult decisions to come that he
wants to bring back economic stability
that he doesn't want to pass a debt
burden or too high a burden onto our
children and grandchildren but he also
says he wants to show compassion how on
Earth do you do those two things at once
well there's going to be measures as
we've already seen the energy cost the
price guarantee to help people cope with
their energy costs uh he's we've said
that's been cut back hasn't it well
we've said that will be reviewed uh for
for the next uh phase so the first six
months is clear and in that review he'll
be focusing on uh on helping the most
vulnerable the most so I think that will
characterize the way in which uh you
know the decisions that he takes are
implemented that they'll be there to
help those who need it most
he also spoke about wanting to bring
forward the best of the conservative
party so in other words bringing in a
cabinet of all the talents perhaps a bit
of a nod to there being jobs for people
who didn't necessarily back him in the
leadership race what would you like to
see from the new cabinet
well I'd like to see
a spread across the party in senior
positions in government using people
who've got established Talent as well as
bringing on some new talents so one of
the challenges that the previous prime
minister had is that her cabinet was
almost entirely made up of those who had
been loyal to her in the vote during the
summer and I think this prime minister
Rishi sunak has the space now to be able
to appoint by Talent rather than by
loyalty
do you think that he will do that then
I'm
you need to ask him whether he will do
it or not my expectation is that that's
exactly what he will do he's got some
very I mean we don't know yet whether
Jeremy Hunt will remain in Poster's
Charter but I would expect that to be
the case and I would imagine that there
will be senior roles for uh for Penny
mordant and others who've who were in
Boris Johnson's cabinet as well as Liz
truss's cabinet as well as people who
are currently on the back benches
it'll be interesting to see I have to
say if only I could ask at Rishi sunak
uh directly who would be in his cabinet
that's definitely something I'd be
taking advantage of right now and just
to reflect on the Liz trust speech no
she was talking about how she acted
urgently and decisively that she was on
side on the side of hard-working people
and then really I guess digging in to
her plan for low growth and lower taxes
as well
do you think that comes across as a bit
tone deaf I guess to a country who are
grappling with high mortgage rates where
the bank of England had to step in to
stop and run on pensions
well I think uh I mean Liz truss has got
a she's been through a very difficult
few weeks it's not surprising to me that
she's uh sort of emphasizing what she
was trying to do which was to inject
dynamism into the economy and the
problem was she was doing it you know at
too fast to Pace without having laid the
groundwork in advance so I'm not
surprised that she uh said the words
that she did I think what is very
encouraging is we've just seen the
statement which you put up a few moments
ago from Boris Johnson expressing his
full support for Rishi sunak as prime
minister and encouraging colleagues to
uh to get behind him and certainly the
mood and the conservative party in
Westminster last night and this morning
is very powerfully that you know we've
we've gone through a difficult period
we're putting it behind us we're looking
forward and in a United Way
and that is the key isn't it whether or
not the conservative party can unite a
Richie's unack said yesterday that the
choice for conservative MPS was unite or
die do you think he was right
well I think we have to to unite we've
gone through a in a relatively well
prolonged to one prolonged and then one
very short leadership contest over the
course of the last uh two to three
months and and at that bit seen by the
country as somewhat self-indulgent I
think now what we have to absolutely
focus on is making the difficult
decisions getting fiscal stability back
into the markets and getting confidence
of the country that the conservatives
are the best people to continue to
govern the country
we're going to do that if we're United
they're absolutely uh right there we'll
wait to see whether or not the
conservative party can unite for more
than a few hours at least behind the new
prime minister thank you very much
okay there you go
well it has been a busy morning here in
Westminster Liz trust the outgoing prime
minister giving her speech on the steps
of Downing Street here with her husband
and daughters behind her uh very much
saying that her plan for growth was the
right one and then of course moments
later or an hour later or so Rishi sunak
at saying mistakes were made so two very
different speeches in tone now he has
just made a speech in Downing Street he
warned as well that difficult decisions
would have to be made as the country
faces what he called a profound economic
crisis
well the form will start over if you see
you next time in office began with an
audience with King Charles that was late
this morning where he was invited to
form a new Administration a little
earlier the king had accepted accepted
the reservation of Liz trust just 49
days after she'd been invited to former
government by the late Queen Elizabeth
good morning
I've just been to Buckingham Palace
and accepted his majesty the king's
invitation to form a government in his
name
it is only right
to explain why I'm standing here
as your new prime minister
right now
our country is facing a profound
economic crisis
the aftermath of covid still lingers
Putin's war in Ukraine has destabilized
energy markets and Supply chains the
world over
I want to pay tribute to my predecessor
Liz Truss
she was not wrong to want to improve
growth in this country
it is a noble aim
and I admired her restlessness to create
change
but some mistakes were made
not born of ill will or bad intentions
quite the opposite in fact
but mistakes nonetheless
and I have been elected as leader of my
party
and your prime minister
in part
to fix them
and that work begins immediately
I will place economic stability and
confidence
at the heart of this government's agenda
this will mean difficult decisions to
come
but you saw me during covid doing
everything I could to protect people and
businesses
with schemes like furlough
there are always limits
more so now than ever
but I promise you this
I will bring that same compassion
to the challenges we face today
the government I lead
will not leave the Next Generation
your children and grandchildren
with a debt to settle that we were too
weak to pay ourselves
I will unite our country
not with words
but with action
I will work day in and day out to
deliver for you
this government
will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
Trust
is earned and I will earn yours
I will always be grateful to Boris
Johnson for his incredible achievements
as prime minister
and I treasure his warmth and generosity
of spirit
and I know he would agree
that the Mandate my party earned in 2019
is not the sole property of any one
individual
it is a mandate
that belongs to
and unites all of us
and the Heart of that mandate is our
Manifesto
I will deliver
on its promise
a stronger NHS
better schools
safer streets
control of our borders protecting our
environment supporting our Armed Forces
leveling up and building an economy that
Embraces the opportunities of brexit
where businesses invest innovate and
create jobs
I understand
how difficult this moment is
after the billions of pounds it cost us
to combat covert after all the
dislocation that caused in the midst of
a terrible war that must be seen
successfully to its conclusions
I fully appreciate how hard things are
and I understand too
that I have work to do to restore trust
after all that has happened
all I can say
is that I am not daunted
I know the high office I have accepted
and I hope to live up to its demands
but when the opportunity to serve comes
along
you cannot question the moment only your
willingness
so I stand here before you
ready to lead our country into the
future
to put your needs above politics
to reach out and build a government that
represents the very best traditions of
my party
together we can achieve incredible
things
we will create a future
worthy of the sacrifices so many have
made
and Phil tomorrow
and every day thereafter
with hope
thank you
well that was Richie sunac's first
speech as prime minister warning of
difficult decisions to come pledging to
put economic credibility at the hearts
of his administration and did have a few
tough words for his predecessor saying
some mistakes were made I've been
elected to fix them well earlier this
trust delivered her final speech as
prime minister and it was pretty
different in time
I wish Rishi sunak every success for the
good of our country
I want to thank you Francis Liberty my
family and friends and all the team at
number 10 for their love friendship and
support
I also want to thank my Protection Team
I look forward to spending more time in
my constituency and continuing to serve
Southwest Norfolk from the back benches
our country continues to battle through
a storm
but I believe in Britain
I believe in the British people
and I know that brighter days lie ahead
thank you
well let's trust their pledging to
continue as an MP from the back benches
and one of a few ex-prime ministers in
Parliament as she walked away from down
the street for the last time with her
husband and
her two daughters
she was then driven away from Downing
Street to make the short journey to
Buckingham Palace for that appointments
with King Charles to hand in her
resignation
[Music]
[Applause]
and around 20 minutes ago the new prime
minister entered number 10 to the cheers
of his new staff waiting for him behind
closed doors
well joining us now to discuss what a
Rishi sunak Premiership means that is
the chair of the labor party and these
dogs
well we know that he's going to be very
different prime minister to lose trust
that much was evident by the two
speeches that they gave this morning on
Downing Street do you think he could be
a bit more formidable opposition to
labor
well unfortunately Rishi sunak has been
at the heart of all of the conservative
failures that we've seen quite frankly
including the apogee that we saw
recently with Liz truss I mean if the
problem overall is the conservative
party then the answer cannot be Rishi
sunak he doesn't have a mandate to be
crowned in this manner we've seen what
three prime ministers now are in just
five months the country did not ask for
this chaos and really we need a fresh
start now we do need to see a general
election for the genuine change that
people need
is it really fair to pin the Liz truss
issues on Richie's soon act though I
mean in the last leadership election he
spent his whole time basically arguing
against her Economic Policy he said it
was fantasy economics and he's done
absolutely zero to support her in the
last month
but we saw a cost of living crisis in
our country before the recent period of
chaos under Liz truss we saw the
creation of that high tax low growth
economy under the conservatives being
built up over the last 12 years of
conservative-led governments and I'm
afraid Rishi sunak was at the heart of
those developments you know nobody voted
for that high tax low growth economy
when they voted conservative in the 2019
election and you know again Rishi sunak
said in his speech that he wanted for
example to focus on leveling up well we
know that as Chancellor he made clear he
actively stopped measures to enable
funds being received by those areas that
need them so really he does not have a
mandate to Simply Be crowned in this way
we do need to see a fresh start
you talked there about the high tax low
growth of the conservative party with
the emphasis on high tax would you like
to see lower taxes now then
well labor has been very clear that we
want to spend wisely untaxed fairly
we've consistently sorry I'm just saying
I'm just going to come in there I'm just
coming because everyone would say they
want to spend wisely and tax fairly it's
quite meaningless really would you like
to see lower taxes now
well it's not meaningless when we've set
out which taxes we would remove and
where we would remove tax loopholes and
you can contrast those actually with
Rishi sunak's record you know we've been
very clear that we would remove those
loopholes for non-doms which mean that
they pay far less tax than people who
live here and pay taxes in the ordinary
way we would do that so that we could
pay for more nurses and more doctors in
our NHS for example we've also said that
for example we would get rid of some of
those tax breaks for property developers
you know labor has been clear that we do
not want to see a high level of Taxation
on working people when there are
alternatives that government could take
you know again we see under the
conservatives a complete unwillingness
and in fact Rishi sunak again was part
of this an unwillingness to use some of
the super profits from oil and gas
companies to get people those bills down
eventually Rishi sunak putting that into
practice but full ultimately of
loopholes when he did adopt a windfall
tax so labor would take very different
approaches to taxation so the choices
that have been made by conservatives
laborers on the side of working people
I'm afraid we have not seen that from
the conservatives and that includes
Rishi sunak
um do you think that Richardson act will
be a better prime minister than Liz
trucks
well I'm afraid the conservatives can
move around the person at the top of
their party but they are still the same
conservatives and we didn't hear from
sunach in his speech any clear
indication in particular of a plan for
growth you know labor set out very
clearly what we would be doing now to
ensure growth in our green Prosperity
plan you know that 2030 energy
decarbonization plan for example getting
rid of business rates replacing them
with a fear attacks and so on we didn't
hear any of that kind of contact content
from Rishi sunak just now so I don't see
that there will be that change I'm
afraid that our country needs what I
don't understand is um you know you're
saying that there's no change between
Rishi sunak and Liz Trask but then
you're criticizing him for not putting
growth at the heart of a speech I mean
that's the point isn't it that he's
trying to do something differently uh to
Liz truss who is all about growth he's
about trying to bring down the debt
burden about trying to get the kind of I
guess the fiscal things back on track
with difficult decisions on tax and
spending I mean that is that's the
difference isn't it
well no I mean ultimately trust's
approach to growth was to see that it's
created by some kind of trickle down
that if you make the wealthiest even
more wealthy and profitable companies
even more profitable that will
automatically create growth it didn't
but actually we've seen under Rishi
sunak and unwillingness to really grip
onto some of the very same issues I just
talked about the non-dom tax system
we're soon act refused to get rid of
that system that benefits some of the
very best of people in our country well
he also hasn't been acting to ensure
that we really have a proper plan for
growth that's what's needed for our
country labor set out those concrete
measures we've done so early we've said
that we would be you know as I mentioned
before decarbonizing our energy Supply
that would give us energy security it
would get people's bills down and it
would create jobs up and down the
country we haven't seen anything like
that but either under Liz trust nor
indeed now I'm afraid under Rishi sunai
but it's what's needed for our country
and you know it's not just me as a labor
politician seeing that we've also heard
from the head of Tesco him saying that
it's only labor who are on the park when
it comes to that genuine commitment to
delivering a plan for growth
okay thank you very much indeed Labor's
annalize Dodds there talking about
Labor's alternative plan for growth and
giving her reaction to Rishi sunak
well we are expecting wish you sooner to
announce this new cabinet later this
afternoon it's going to be one of the
biggest Clues as to what a new
Administration is likely to look like
he's talked about bringing the best of
the party to the force so there is
perhaps a hint and a suggestion that he
might be trying to bring in at Talent
from all sides of the party including
those at Hidden